[Music]
now you're back on the east coast ready
to do what's right tomorrow on election
day
and [ __ ] put in the vault i can't
vote i got the felonies you forget
i'm i'm not voting i'm not voting i'm
hoping i think it's time for a dictator
enough enough of letting the russians
meddle in our elections
it's time for us to have a dictator so
the russians can't do that anymore
i'm ready to move on from democracy
jesus [ __ ] christ you're giving up to
the comedies already
those were the days where your parents
or your uncle or whatever just took you
to the movie they were going
i remember my parents back then they
took me to see like movies like jagged
edge
and then i wouldn't sleep for like two
three weeks yeah i would just drag you
wherever they were going
my grandfather didn't give a [ __ ] no
they didn't give a [ __ ]
my grandfather in the in the 90s mid 90s
me and and my cousin he would watch us
during the day while our moms worked
he took us i would to green acres mall
out in uh in nassau county took us
green naked small he took us to see
don't be menaced to south central while
drinking juice in the hood
and fell asleep and then he took us to
see the movie clueless that's what we
would see
and we saw each movie like five times in
the summer but i mean don't be mad south
central drinking juice in the hood
it's just i mean it's sex drugs and this
guy would just be sleeping because he
didn't take his diabetes medicine
and that's just what it was and that was
like being a kid that was great
now it's like if you did that my grandpa
would be in jail it's [ __ ] it sucks
it's crazy it's [ __ ] crazy how when i
go up north
i live in south jersey when i drive
north i'm old so i gotta pee
i can't [ __ ] pull my dick on the side
of the road and be no more
i know if you get a ticket for paying
you got to register as a sex offender
i know that yeah my brother got a ticket
for peeing
and he had to register as a [ __ ] sex
offender so now i got to [ __ ]
pull over three times every time i you
can't pick out the penis
the last four years i lived there it was
until i came back
to shoot uh the prequel to the sopranos
i was here for three weeks and i really
enjoyed what was happening in my life
there was no [ __ ] that that uh
that feeling of i can't this not
degenerate but that
that's just not even needy it's like uh
i don't even know what to call it it
bleeds on to you
and when you're away from it you feel it
the desperation
when you're away from l.a you go wow
i'm not bumping into desperate [ __ ]
people anymore
well there's an honesty here like in new
york you meet a [ __ ]
you know waiter the guy's a waiter you
meet a contractor the guy's a contractor
in la
nine times out of ten you meet somebody
that whatever job they're doing is just
to buy time until they become
a famous movie star whatever they want
so everybody's
sitting in their own [ __ ] for a long
time we're in new york i feel like
at least there's a sense here where it's
like hey you are who you are and you
kind of just got to accept it it's like
if you're not going to make the movies
kid it's like you got to find a way to
pay the bills the rent and shit's too
high here
where la i think they can live on this
dream a little bit longer and also i
feel like la
it's just it's a lot of times at the
city of you know who's the most
most cutthroat person in your [ __ ]
class moves out to la to try to become a
movie star or director and the city is
full of just cutthroat people
that have no roots there where new york
is like you know
my family's been here for over 100 years
and nobody thinks about leaving you know
even me i only go to la for a few weeks
and come back because i want to just try
to make my career and my opportunities
here i don't want to leave you know
um but la it's like you kind of just go
there temporarily try to make it big
and then come back but that's why i
think somebody like you you did what you
wanted to do on your own terms and now
you're back
and you can make just as much money have
just as much fame as these guys in the
movies by doing
from home in in new jersey and being
with your daughter every day it's a
beautiful life
it's uh listen i i'm not saying i drank
the kool-aid
but the first three or four years i
listened
to what they were saying to me you know
do this on stage
and then one day i'm like what am i a
[ __ ] monkey
i didn't come here to play to their song
i'm doing this my [ __ ] way
right and i i changed my stand up you
know if you talk to rogan he'll say that
i was struggling for a long time and one
day it just hit me
it was about 2001 where i was like
[ __ ] these [ __ ] [ __ ] the
montreal comedy festival
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] them off you're doing
stand-up to be
funny right not to [ __ ] you know
i heard people coming up to me going you
know you got to change your material
it's got to be about your family they
have to see your sitcom
what [ __ ] sick time are you talking
about i got no [ __ ] sick toms i'm
doing dirty comedy
nothing bothers me when somebody calls
me a celebrity that
i'd rather you call me a fat [ __ ]
spicer
don't [ __ ] you're in the right place
don't call me a [ __ ] celebrity i'm
not a celebrity i'm a dirty [ __ ]
comic
book lucky [ __ ] that giannis every time
you eat hummus
isis gets a dollar
thomas is just making isis stronger by
the way
isis has been very quiet during the
pandemic day sure
yeah yeah because because the news cycle
they they're not the isis doesn't sell
tickets right now only covert sells
tickets but once coving's over
once that's over isis is going to be
next up to sell the tickets
yeah i love to be a recurring guest on
your show
and every time we come on you teach me
about a little bit of history
just a little bit dick just a little bit
tell me why
germans did this why the [ __ ] nazis
did that
why the polox did this why the chinese
built our railroads
i want you to teach me every time yeah
and i promise to be a recurring guest
if you have a lesson for me every time
it's what it is i'm getting old
and i'm kind of forgetting and you guys
are young guys you got i'm passing the
torch on to you [ __ ]
so every time uncle joey comes on you
give me a little history lesson
that's what it is it's about abe lincoln
jerking off or
the emancipation proclamation whatever
betsy ross
you know whatever whatever yeah she
makes a nice flag that lady
we would love to have you if you she
does betsy ross made the first make
tonight and speaking of bets
i'll be in philadelphia november 19 to
the 21st you [ __ ] yeah
[Music]